good evening members and officers
thank you for joining us this evening at
the executive meeting on
this thursday the 4th of november 2021
if i can move first to agenda item 1
apologies for absence
the
only apology that i've received is from
councillor mike webb
moving to agenda item 2
non-members attended attending there are
none
minutes of the meeting
agenda item 3
held on the 7th of october 2021
members are the minutes correct
can i have a show of hands we'll
thank you
agenda item 4 to receive declarations of
interest
are there any declarations of interest
on any of the items tonight
none declared
moving to agenda item 5 members on
questions on notice from councillors
and there are none
which takes us to agenda item six
matters referred to the executive and
reports from other committees
members there are none
moving on to agenda item seven
we go to our first substantive item of
the evening which is the quarter 2 20 21
22
financial management report and at that
point i will pass over to councillor
simon smith
for the
introduction of the report and an update
councillor smith thank you chairman um
with the tremendous assistance of naomi
and her team i'd like to
read out the following report so the
purpose of the report is to set out
the forecast revenue and capital budget
positions at the end of quarter two
the latest revenue budget is eleven
million four hundred and thirty six
thousand pounds
changes to the original budget are due
to drawdowns from reserves which are
detailed in appendix one
the forecast outrun at quarter one is
eleven million one hundred and sixty
nine thousand pounds which gives a
projected underspend of 268 000 pounds
after applying the council's cove this
is after account applying the council's
covert 19 general grant allocation but
before additional funding from the
government's income compensation scheme
i would say that that
is something that may lead to a fairly
positive position for us and
i would like to effectively express our
my my appreciation uh on behalf of the
council to the government's covered
measures to help district councils
the variances across individual
portfolio budgets are set out in more
detail in the budget but in the body of
the report and at appendix 2.
the council continues to feel the impact
of kobit 19 on its budgets particularly
on car parking income which is currently
forecast to be nearly four hundred
thousand pounds under budget
we report regularly on our expected
financial positions related to the
pandemic to the government
the council's coveted 19 grant
allocation to cover general pandemic
related pressures in 2122
is 341 000 pounds
other specific covert grants are
detailed in appendix 5.
the government has also continued its
income compensation scheme for the cur
first quarter of 2122
at the time of writing the report the
amount of compensation for rocha
district council was not yet confirmed
and so it's not included in the
projected outrun figures
the position will continue to be closely
monitored for the remainder of the year
will inform the budget setting process
for
2022-23 onwards
the original capital program for 2122
was
3.6 million pounds
as part of the close down in 2021
0.5 of a million of carry forwards were
agreed creating a revised budget of 4.1
million
the forecasted outrun on the council's
capital programme as at quarter 2 is now
only
1.459 million
the major item with with slippage
against the revised 2122 budget is the
asset development program which accounts
for nearly two million pounds of the
capital budget this year and is pending
the agreement of the first stop go
decision point
the table in annex 3 summarises the
projected capital provision by service
area
thank you chairman and obviously we're
happy to take any questions
councillor smith thank you very much
indeed
members are there any questions
council award
yes actually through you chairman um on
this one it goes to
page 7.19
on
the document
um i i noticed that um
within
the direction uh the the
planning directory that we
have done very well
but
just wanted to know
why we haven't done so well
on planning fee income
i know it's not necessarily on your part
but it's quite disappointing
to see that we've had no
as far as the pre-apps are concerned
that has dropped down is there any
reason
why that would be because i'm sure that
people will look at this
and they i
felt i needed to ask that question
as to is there a reason why
the pre-apps have dropped even though
other things have gone on so well
council award thank you very much indeed
for your uh question uh i don't know
whether that's a uh answer that uh
uh the assistant director marcus hotten
is able to give now we'll come back to
you later he's i'm getting a uh a nod so
uh over to you marcus
it's it's cyclical in nature uh so at
times it you have good years and bad
years i mean it's just the nature of the
beast
in that sense um so it really depends on
the type of applications that are coming
through
there are some of the smaller free
applications that we are not processing
uh at this time but in terms of the
income the significant income is usually
from large scale
pre-applications so it's as we're coming
towards the end of the of our local plan
if you wish then those allocations are
dwinding down and so as a new local plan
starts with a new set of allocations and
what you see is a whole new wave of
pre-applications coming in so it's not
too surprising
thank you
thank you councillor warden thank you mr
hotland for your response members are
there any other questions
i'm not seeing any other
indications so
i will
well just before i move to the
recommendation i certainly would like to
echo my thanks to naomi lucas assistant
director resources
and certainly under the stewardship of
councillor simon smith as portfolio
holder
and indeed all officers
we know that money is not plentiful
but i believe we should be very proud of
the way there is strict control and
responsible control of the way in which
we manage our affairs within the
authority so
from the executive to
officers
i extend my thanks
and i know that
day-to-day it's not easy to
to do what you do very very effectively
so i will
move to
the one recommendation set out at
paragraph 1.1
and that is to note the quarter 2 20 21
22 revenue budget and capital position
set out in sections 3 and 4 and detailed
in appendices one to five members is
that noted
thank you very much
moving on to agenda item eight the
leisure contract operational update in
normal circumstances council of webb
would have introduced this report but as
i said at the start
he is
he has sent his apologies um this
evening and
in his absence i will ask assistant
director matt harwood white if you would
be kind enough please to
introduce us into the report thank you
thank you chairman evening members
the purpose of the report this evening
is to provide an operational update on
the council's leisure contract
uh before this evening at a meeting of
the executive in december 2020 the
contract was extended until march 2025
this operational update report covers a
period from january to october 2021 and
gives a summary of the operation of the
facilities during that time
members fusion's approach to reopening
of facilities following the covenant
force closures has been shaped by
central government advice
and national governing bodies of sports
and trade associations such as uk active
and swim england
their objective has been to create a
kobe 19 secure facility that customers
and staff and giving them confidence to
return to the centers
members table one in the report sets out
a timeline of the main operational
changes at the centers as they've
occurred since reopening in march 2021
in response to the cobit 19 restrictions
being relaxed over time
members section 6 of the report
sets out the participation of the sites
fusion's key performance indicator for
participation in 2021 22 are guided by
uk active projections
as a recovery of the leisure market and
was set in march of this year
so members table 2 that details the
target participation figures and the
actual participation figures for both
sites for april to september 2021 and
additionally the target participation
figures for october to march 2022.
remember some police report that
participation at both clemencial and
radio leisure center has broadly been in
line with these targets up to and
including the end of september 2021.
remember section 7 of the report moving
on focuses on customer feedback
this sets out the process followed for
recording and monitoring feedback at the
sites
positive comments have been received
regarding the covert secure measures put
in place by fusion at the centers
however negative feedback has been
received regarding booking systems
programming and opening hours
members officers meet regularly with
fusion at a local and senior and
regional level to ensure that these
concerns are being properly investigated
and addressed
officers have fed back to fusion that
their communication needs to be
significantly improved
in addition opportunities have been
missed for example to highlight changes
to the offer within the centers and to
clarify any issues being raised by
members for example with the booking
system
as i said members these issues have been
escalated with fusion and will be
continued to be monitored at a senior
level
moving on to section 8 of the report
investments
fusion have committed to invest in our
centers
i'm pleased to report this includes new
gym equipment worth approximately
000 pounds combined at both sites
clements and radio leisure centre
that's just the start of that investment
process that's front of house other
things happening in terms of
repairs to our roof works at the sites
both clements and ray leisure center
investment in plant rooms and sports
hall flooring to name a few
moving on to section 9 of the report
this focuses on active communities so
this is the outreach work that fusion
take part in and lead
they work closely with our active
rochford network accessing funding to
deliver a number of projects and these
are detailed and report across the
district
section 10 focuses on the financial
position and as reported to exactly last
year a new schedule of unity payments
were agreed with fusion to reflect their
projected recovery plan following the
pandemic
it's anticipated assets out in the
report the full amount will be paid in
2122
due to the additional lockdown and
restrictions and restriction measures in
the early part of the year
which put further pressure on the
financial projections
the performance is reviewed monthly by
officers in consultation with the
council's 151 officer on a fully open
book basis
and that process undertaken follows
external advisor guidance and advice
that we follow through
section 10.6
focuses on fusion's financial statements
it sets out that accounts have been
prepared on a going concern basis and
have been signed up by the external
auditors as such
however in as noted in the report there
are material uncertainties that make
cause significant doubt upon the group
and charities ability to continue as a
growing concern these are inherent to
the pandemic itself
however
fusion detail a number of mitigations
which we put in place to minimize this
risk
these include a significant
restructuring of the company and
securing 30 million pounds worth of
government-backed loans the sea bills
loans as they're known
specifically for the purpose of
supporting recovery from the pandemic
fusion themselves state that these
measures support financial projections
in which the business is cash generative
and able to return to an accounting
surplus within the year
in closing chairman
the report sets out a draft timeline in
terms of the tasks necessary looking
forward uh to explore options and
opportunities the leisure service
provision at the end of this contract
given its own just been extended we
still need to think ahead and look
forward to next steps work in
consultation with the portfolio holder
and the leader
an initial
report to set out draft priorities
objectives and timeline to explore these
options will be brought to the executive
in the summer of next year
jim that concludes my initial
presentation happy to take any questions
thank you
thank you mr harwood white
members any questions on that very
comprehensive report
i'm not seeing any uh indications
um
i would just like to say i've taken a
keen interest
as mr harwood white knows
in holding fusion to account for the
leisure provision in our district
and
on a number of occasions i've met their
chief executive along with other senior
officers
and i don't underestimate for one moment
the difficulty there has been through
the
virus period of maintaining leisure
provision when we were locked down taken
out of lockdown and then reintroduced
into lockdown and the operational
difficulties that presents in terms of
managing
staff and managing the facilities there
in terms of
negotiation
i think
you along with your other officers did
us proud in terms of negotiating the
arrangements
the providers
of this sort of service
are
obviously in a
position coming out of covid not all
clamoring for the business and so to
have been able to sustain a contract for
a further three years
and keep business running at our two
prime leisure centres i think is a
credit to you and your team and indeed
to to the
providers
that doesn't mean to say that everything
runs smoothly and mr harwood white will
know that i'm regularly on the phone to
him
talking about some of the frontline
issues which i frankly still have
concerns with
and we will continue to work in the
interests of our residents to get the
best possible arrangements in place
and
you know so it's
extremely good news
that we've been able to reopen in the
way but we need to ensure that some of
the operational
aspects are
tightly attended to
so
i do thank you i'm proud of the
investment
real investment that is going in
i know that there were views at the time
we
helped fusion financially but i believe
that in the short to medium term we will
be more than recompensed
with the investment in the business so
and i think that was part of the deal
that you struck
with fusion as we came out of the uh
as we are coming out of the pandemic so
thank you very much indeed for that
so
with that
unless there's any further comments or
questions and i will go to
the recommendation set out of paragraph
1.1 and that is to note the operational
update on the council's leisure contract
with fusion lifestyle members is that
noted
thank you very much indeed
we move then to
agenda item 9
contract monitoring
and
angela law assistant director legal and
democratic will introduce the report
please
angela thank you chairman
um there is a requirement under our
contract procedure rules to report on
the contract monitoring of its main
contracts
i'm i'm not proposing to go through this
report verbatim but
in brief contract managers are
responsible for ensuring that there is a
proactive approach to contract
monitoring
which is essential for ensuring that our
contractors meet their legal obligations
an outline of the processes and outcomes
for
april 2020 to march 2021 is set out in
appendix a of the
ict
street cleansing services waste
management leisure management
grounds maintenance
materials recycling facility for the
procurement system
revenues and benefit system and
temporary accommodation
the aeds are here
to answer any questions which members
may have regarding those contracts
thank you very much indeed angela
are there any questions
councillor smith
thank you chairman um
obviously the report
is sort of generally under the finance
portfolio
just to add
further to
what what our officers described to us
um i i wouldn't like anyone to who was
listening to this recording at a later
stage to think that
this report is the some extent of our
contract monitoring i just refer members
back to the to to item eight
which show which
is where we have the detail and depth of
how these contracts are managed on a
day-to-day basis by highly skilled teams
of officers working behind the scenes
making sure that all these things are
right so what we have here in front of
us is just a high level strategic
overview but it is far far from the sum
total of how the council
administers its contracts which is
exceptionally thorough but behind the
scenes thank you
thank you councillor smith
are there any other
statements or questions that anyone
wishes to
add
no in that case i will go to um
recommendations set out at paragraph 1.1
to note the operational update on the
council's leisure contract with fusion
lifestyle members is that noted
i beg your pardon
and thank you angela for pointing that
out um
right we moved to paragraph 1.1 the
trouble is there's a lot of 1.1s tonight
so uh hence i saw the wrong 1.1 um
so to note the process at 1.1 and
outcomes of contract monitoring for the
council's most significant contracts in
terms of contract value and risk the
requirement for this report is set out
in section 22 of the council's contract
procedure rules and follows
recommendations from external audit is
members is that noted
right just to get this absolutely clear
1.1 is that the contents of the report
be noted
and i've just read out 1.2 i don't think
i need to read it out again um but
we've noted that as well
thank you and thank you
monitoring officer for keeping me on the
straight and narrow on that one thank
you very much indeed
right
we moved to agenda item 10 exclusion of
the present public
members of the public of which of whom
there's no one actually sitting in the
audience tonight but there may be some
listening at home
we've come to the end of the business
that we can debate with you uh the
remaining report contains exempt
information and i will therefore be
asking that you now leave the meeting
and the
recording is terminated for this period
of
confidential business
so it is